- I was talking about like
some of my favorite
moments from Charlie's,
boarding Lucy's plane to Tokyo
with Tom Green in toe.
You duct taping up the
girls in the racing suit.
I love when you were the, you know,
what do you guys like?
What's, what is one of
your favorite memories?
- Well, some of it's not on film.
- Yeah.
- For me it was like,
I had joined you guys.
You were already in training
and you know,
you guys were so welcoming.
I came in, you guys gave me huge hugs
and then we started training
and you're like, you're doing so great,
you're doing so great
and I felt like I'm doing really great.
(laughing)
And then the next day I could not move.
I was immobilized.
(laughing)
I was so flexible the first day
and then I literally, I
couldn't even bend over.
I was like, I'm in so much pain.
And then we used to do acupuncture
and I mean, it was a matter of survival
just getting through
that training session.